[Music]
at an online TV channel in Kiev set up
to show a Russian audience what's
happening in the war there's breaking
news pro-ukrainian Russian activists
have claimed an attack on the Russian
Border Town of Belgrade
the Channel's founder ilyaponomarev is
excited by the events he says Putin's
ruined the country he comes from Ilia
was a Russian MP until he was banned
from the country for voting against the
annexation of Crimea in 2014.
the channel was created in the very
first days of the invasion to counter
Russian propaganda because we have a
ridiculous situation when firstly all
Russians are being brainwashed by
Russian state
the money he made as a tech investor in
the U.S
being a Critic of Vladimir Putin is
risky even outside of Russia
particularly running a TV channel like
this maxilla even more high profile and
visible but he says he's not scared and
I have numerous friends already
unfortunately who died at this at this
war and I will just betray them if you
know if I'll be scared and I will be
hiding somewhere
correspondence in Russia have to hide
their identity for safety in Kiev the
teams mostly made up of Ukrainian
journalists Peter zalmayev is a
household name of top TV news anchor who
drops in to host shows to help despite
all the Crackdown on media in Russia the
the last crucial step hasn't been taken
Russia has not been YouTube we're taking
advantage of this loophole so to speak
to reach an increasing number of uh the
Russian audience
two and a half million people tuned in
last month Ilya says his channel is
showing the other side of the story he
hopes it'll Empower activists in Russia
and help bring change in the country he
once called home
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Keith
is a defensive military analyst